-Welcome to the show, you guys.
-[ Laughs ] Thank you.
-Thank you.
-This is our first
tri-split screen,
so I'm very excited
from a technical point of view
on our end.
But, also,
I'm a big fan of the show.
Congrats on "PEN15."
-Thank you.
-It was a huge hit, season one.
So, obviously, season two
is coming right now.
It's on everyone's
what-to-watch list.
You play 13-year-olds trying to
survive middle school in 2000.
Uh, why middle school?
Was that always the plan?
-Yeah, I mean, we knew we wanted
to do a show about rejects
and something messed up and sad,
so naturally we kept coming back
to middle school.
But we couldn't
quite figure it out.
I feel like when the first --
Our first show idea was,
like, we were in a cult,
and we were escaping a cult --
It wasn't convoluted at all.
-Yeah.
-And then we hide
in a foster family.
And then we, like, start
attending middle school
to just kind of,
you know, hide, right, Maya?
-Ooh.
-Yeah, it started out like that.
And then -- But then, like,
right as we were, like,
coming up with that idea,
we're like,
"Oh, we're escaping a cult.
This is brilliant."
Tina Fey, like, just came out
with "Unbreakable
Kimmy Schmidt."
-"Kimmy Schmidt."
It's the same thing, yeah.
-Okay.
-Yeah, that's better.
-What are the odds
of that happening?
-I know. It's crazy.
But then our third co-creator,
who's our friend, he was like,
"Why do you need a cult and all?
Like, it's enough to just be 13.
Like, that's a hell
in and of itself.
Like, you don't need
all of this extra framework."
-Yeah.
-So we just did that.
-And season two premieres
on Friday.
The second half is going to
come out once it's safe.
-Yeah. Probably not
for a year or so, yeah.
-It's wild to know, like,
you're both in your 30s.
And I immediately forget
that you're not actually 13.
Do you -- Look at the --
I mean, it's insane.
-Physically,
we are being transformed.
Like, we wear breast straps,
essentially.
And then we wear, like,
these tight low-rider jeans.
So it's sort of like a sausage
casing that you get, like,
you know, squished
from both ends.
To have your, like,
stomach pop out.
And that's, like, so --
Part of being in middle school,
I feel like you're
always hunching over, like,
trying to hide these body parts
that are just developing
or coming at, you know,
different speeds really fast.
-Interesting.
-When we were coloring
the season,
when we were doing post,
the colorist kept being like,
"So, there's, like,
a lot of wrinkles here.
Do you want me to
just feather that out?
Want me to just take that out?"
I was very tempted to say yes.
We didn't.
So you'll just see 13-year-old
wrinkles all the time.
But I think the other giveaway
for me was, like, okay,
mentally I can get
into character,
but physically my body
kept giving out on me.
We had --
Because, you know, I'm 33
and maybe not as physically fit
as most 33-year-olds.
And we had this scene
where we had to run for, like,
I don't know, 10 feet?
It felt like more.
-That sounds --
That sounds tough.
-It was really, really hard.
And I started getting
these, like, crazy
leg spasms and back spasms,
which was really embarrassing.
Because I had my braces on.
I'm, like, holding --
I'm, like, trying
with all my might --
-You kept being like,
"Maya, slow down."
And I'd be, like, walking.
I'm like, "We got to, like,
somehow speed this up."
-And then we ended up having,
like, the most humiliating thing
of all, of having a chair,
at the end of the 10 feet,
with a bunch of ice packs
and, like, three people
to, like, catch me.
-Oh, my God. That is so sad.
It's loosely based on your
lives, the show, "PEN15,"
for those that haven't seen it.
I thought it would be fun to see
what you were actually like
at that age.
We have a photo of you from 13.
I was wondering if you can
give us a few superlatives.
Maya, here is your photo.
Now, what is --
What would her superlative be?
-Okay, so,
one superlative would be...
most likely to show a VHS video
of "Sex and the City"
to her friend
and then get yelled at
and shamed by the parents
for showing it.
-Oh. You were that kid?
-You were that kid.
-But what's crazy is
I was, like, the prudest kid.
I had not done anything
at that point.
But yet I was, like, watching
all of this R-rated content.
And all the friends I was
showing it to were, like,
going far. I mean,
they were, like, doing...
-Things.
-...a lot of things.
-Going far...?
-Going far sexually.
Like, they were doing things
that were being talked about
on the show, but I got, you
know, shamed for showing it.
-Yeah, like, you were the one
that invented that, yeah.
Anna, I want to show
a photo of you.
Here's you.
-Please don't.
-Happy new year!
-My has blessed surprised me
with confetti,
and I'm smiling,
but I couldn't be more annoyed.
[ Laughter ]
-You're actually -- How --
What would the superlatives
for this human be?
-I feel like something like...
most likely to be
at her best friend's house
but hang out with
her best friend's parents.
-Really?
-Or something like that.
I would end up a lot of times
with the parents and being like,
"How are your parents?
How are those ailments going?"
-Wow.
-"Are they getting better?"
Yeah.
-I love that.
-I was, like,
a little socially awkward.
-You wanted to hang out
with the older crowd.
Well, the show is super funny.
I'm so excited
for the second season.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here are Maya Erskine
and Anna Konkle
in season 2 of "PEN15."
Take a look.
-I'd rather go to jail!
-Maya, that's you.
-Line?
-"I'd rather go to jail than
spend one more minute with you."
-I have it. Thank you.
-To your left.
Your left. The other left.
-Anna, let me finish the line.
-Hold. Go on 32. Hold.
Hold, I said. Hold.
Hold! Hold.
-We're just getting up.
-Hold.
Walk it through slowly
so we can get the mark.
-I'll hit you with my own...
-Slower physical.
-[ Speaking indistinctly ]
-Faster vocal.
-I saw you backing away
from Sheila.
Sheila was a rat bastard.
-Thank you for doing this.
And congratulations again
on the show.
Season two of "PEN15"
premieres this Friday on Hulu.
We'll be right back with a
performance from Summer Walker.
Come on back.
Thanks again, guys.
-Thank you.